I think Bobby clot might have a hard
time with this question since they are
both very close with their respective
siblings my name is Vince and my brother
and I are both in our mid 30s he lives
in Missouri and I live in California the
issue is that my bro has not come down
to visit me since 2009 my parents and I
are the ones who always have to make the
trip to him he makes plans to come down
with his family but then cancels I'm
contemplating on only going out there
every other year or not go up go there
until he starts coming to me what do you
suggest so I guess he wants a close
relationship with his brother but he's
doing all the work work yeah is your
brother
financially able to you know travel to
is in Minnesota mm-hmm Missouri in
California
Oh Missouri in California I mean if he's
financially able to and he's just not
doing it I probably know the reason why
why because we the brothers in
California right yeah Californians are
they live very very cushy lazy lives and
when we think about traveling to another
state we just we sort of a kind of
elitist in that way we're like no
everyone comes to California this is
where you need to be so we think that
everyone has to make the trip out here
and I understand that I know some people
who are like that and sometimes I'm a
little bit like that that doesn't come
from a bad place other than why do I
have to go there you can come here it's
so much better here but it isn't you
know it yeah but even if my brother
lived in Omaha yeah right I'd be like
you know what I'm gonna go to Oh mom me
too because they have cattle probably
great steaks true right and I I you know
when I go like I'm gonna tell you a
story I was in El Paso Texas with the
Carlos Mencia when I was young I was
opening for him
and he goes aim April I know this guy
that's barbecue restaurant but they're
they're open now but they're opening for
us
I go okay so we go to this like white
look like a house but it was definitely
a restaurant could had an awning we
walked in and the first thing that came
out was this loaf of bread but you could
see the steam coming off of it it just
come out of the oven right and when you
cut it right it's just so soft
and just the best put the butter the
with little chive and it was the best
bread I've ever had
and I got I'll never get a bread like
this in LA right so I would probably
visit my brother anywhere cuz I love him
yeah I you're you're right I'm having a
little bit of trouble answering this
question because I say this before your
feet are so [ __ ] dirty right now I'm
sweaty no look at your feet right now
they're dirty they're sweaty and dirty
because when they're sweaty they pick up
dirt from the carpet [ __ ] crazy
Seth somebody who hasn't washed her
jeans in six years I know my feet are in
Christie you don't visit your brother
advice is don't visit your brother that
[ __ ] your brother no that's [ __ ]
shut up George he should he should
absolutely see you no matter where you
are if my sister was in some [ __ ]
like scientific mission and Antarctica
I'd go visit her there this is the
weirdest podcast I've done no it isn't
no no I feel great about it I think it's
the best for me is the best because I
just kind of think about what happened
and it was just like all over the place
[Music]